No sé ustedes, pero Yo aún no he descubierto
lo que significa la tecnología en mi vida.
El último año lo he dedicado a pensar sobre el tema.
¿Debería ser pro tecnología? ¿Debería adoptarla sin restricciones?
¿o con cautela? Como Uds., estoy tentado a hacer lo último.
Sin embargo, por otro lado, hace un par de años
me deshice de mis pertenencias,
vendí mi tecnología, a excepción de una bicicleta
con la que hice casi 5000 kms por las carreteras de EEUU con la energía de mi propio cuerpo
alimentado con bollitos industriales de crema además de otra comida basura.
(Risas)
Y desde entonces he intentado mantener en muchos aspectos la tecnología
a distancia para que no domine mi vida.
Al mismo tiempo, administro una página web en “cool tools”
donde diariamente vivo mi pasión: lo último en tecnología.
Y sigo perplejo acerca del verdadero significado de la tecnología
en relación a la humanidad, a la naturaleza
y a lo espiritual.
Y todavía no estoy seguro si sabemos que es tecnología.
Una de las definiciones de tecnología es aquello que se registró por primera vez.
Éste es el primer ejemplo de la utilización de la tecnología moderna que he podido encontrar.
Se trata del plan de estudios propuesto para hacer frente a
las Artes y las Ciencias Aplicadas en la Universidad de Cambridge en 1829.
Antes de eso, obviamente, la tecnología no existía. Pero, evidentemente, sí que existía.
Hay una buena definición que Alan Kay tiene para la tecnología.
Dice que la tecnología es todo lo que se inventó después de que Ud. naciera.
(Risas)
Así que resume bastante de lo que hablamos.
Danny Hillis ha actualizado esa definición
dice que la tecnología es aquello que no funciona todavía.
(Risas)
Lo que va un poco en la dirección, creo, de nuestra idea.
Pero me interesaba otra definición de tecnología.
Algo que se remonta a algo más fundamental.
Algo más profundo. Y como he forcejeado por entenderlo,
he llegado a una especie de metodología para abordar el tema
que parece funcionar en mis investigaciones.
Y hoy voy a hablar de esto por primera vez.
Por tanto, éste no es más que un burdo intento de pensar en voz alta.
La pregunta que surgió fue a raíz de la siguiente pregunta,
¿a qué aspira, qué desea la tecnología? Y con esto, no me refiero
a que si desea chocolate o vainilla. Con ello me refiero
a cuál es la moda y tendencia típica.
¿Qué corrientes imperan a lo largo del tiempo? Una forma de abordarlo
es pensar en organismos biológicos, muy en boga actualmente.
Y usar el truco aplicado por Richard Dawkins, es decir,
percibirlos simplemente como genes, como vehículos de los genes.
Así que la pregunta sería, ¿qué quieren los genes? El gen egoísta.
Y yo aplico el mismo procedimiento para preguntarme
¿y si examinamos el universo de nuestra cultura
a través de los ojos de la tecnología? ¿A qué aspira la tecnología?
Evidentemente, esta pregunta es incompleta,
como también observar un organismo, sólo a través de un gen
es una manera incompleta de observación.
Sí es incompleta pero hoy por hoy sigue siendo muy productiva. Así,
Así si recogemos la visión del mundo de la tecnología, nos preguntamos ¿qué persigue?
Una vez hecha la pregunta
nos remontaremos, en realidad, a la vida en sí. Porque obviamente,
si seguimos nuestra mirada atrás sobre los orígenes de la tecnología
en algún momento volvemos a lo que es la vida.
Así que a partir de ahí es donde quiero comenzar mi pequeña aportación, a partir de la vida.
Y, como Uds. han podido escuchar de los oradores anteriores,
no sabemos muy bien qué vida concreta existe ahora en la Tierra.
Realmente no tenemos idea.
El enorme y brillante intento de Craig Venter
de secuenciar el ADN en el océano es grande.
El trabajo de Brian Farrell es parte de este programa;
intentar descubrir todas las especies sobre la Tierra.
Y una de las cosas que se debería hacer es tejer una red del planeta
y al azar ir e inspeccionar todos los lugares donde se cruza la red,
para comprobar la existencia de la vida. Y si hiciéramos
con nuestra pequeña sonda marciana, lo que no hemos hecho en la Tierra,
descubriríamos algunas especies increíbles.
Esto no es en otro planeta. Se trata de seres
ocultos en nuestro planeta.
Ésta es una hormiga que almacena la miel de sus compañeras en el abdomen.
Cada uno de estos seres que hemos descrito, que han visto
de Jamie y otros, estos entes magníficos,
lo que hacen cada uno de ellos
es boicotear las reglas de la vida.
No puedo pensar en un único principio general de la biología
que no tenga su excepción en algún organismo.
Esto aplica para cada cosa que podamos pensar;
y si escuchan a Olivia Judson hablar sobre hábitos sexuales,
se darán cuenta de que no existen reglas definitivas para todos los seres.
Porque cada uno se salta alguna.
Aquí tenemos una babosa de mar alimentada por energía solar. Es un molusco nudibranquio
que ha incorporado en su interior el cloroplasto para convertirlo en energía.
Ésta es otra versión de lo mismo. Éste es un dragón de mar,
y la imagen inferior, la azul, es uno menor que aún no ha
tragado ácido, es decir, aún no ha ingerido
el alga verde-marrón para dar energía al cuerpo.
Son piratas, y si nos fijamos en los enfoques
propuestos para clasificar la vida, existen, según el consenso actual,
seis reinos. Seis diferentes divisiones: plantas,
animales, hongos, protistas y los procariotas,
bacterias y arqueas.
Así se dividen los seres vivos. Es una manera de conceptuar la vida en la Tierra hoy en día.
Pero otra manera más interesante si cabe,
sería la adopción de una perspectiva a largo plazo,
observar desde una perspectiva evolutiva.
Y aquí vemos una panorámica de la evolución que en vez de
ir lineal con en tiermpo, tiene que salir desde el centro.
Y es el centro el indicador más antiguo, aquí les muestro una gráfica genealógica
de todos los seres vivos en la Tierra. Aquí podemos ver los seis reinos.
4000 especies representativas y aquí se ve donde estamos.
Pero lo que me gusta de esto es ver que
cada ser vivo sobre la Tierra hoy ha evolucionado por igual.
Los hongos y bacterias han evolucionado tanto como los seres humanos.
Ha sucedido en torno al mismo periodo de tiempo pasando por
la misma sucesión de ensayo y error hasta llegar aquí.
Pero vemos que cada uno de ellos se salta la norma
y tiene una forma diferente de cómo construir vida.
Y si miramos las tendencias a largo plazo de la vida y nos preguntamos,
¿qué quiere la evolución? Veremos varias cosas.
Una de las cosas acerca de la evolución es que nada en la tierra
hemos estado alguna vez en la que no encontramos la vida
Encontramos vida al final de cada larga era,
perforando a mucha profundidad en el centro de una roca
a la superficie y ahí hay bacterias en los poros de la roca.
Y donde la vida existe, nunca se retira. Es omnipresente y aspira a más.
Más y más de materia inerte del planeta
está siendo acariciada y vivificada por la vida.
Lo segundo es la diversidad. También vemos la especialización.
Observamos el movimiento de una célula general
a la más específica y especializada.
Y vemos una tendencia hacia la complejidad muy intuitiva.
Y, de hecho, los datos actuales muestran
que existe un cambio hacia la complejidad real a lo largo del tiempo.
Y por último recupero nuevamente el nudibranquio.
Una de las cosas que constatamos es que la vida se mueve
desde el interior para aumentar la sociabilidad. Lo que significa que
existe más y más vida allí cuyo entorno vital completo se identifica por formas de vida diferentes.
Al igual que las células de los cloroplastos
están rodeadas completamente por otras formas de vida.
Y nunca tocan el interior de la materia. Hay cada vez más co-evolución.
Y en general, las largas tendencias de la evolución
se resumen en cinco: la omnipresencia, la diversidad, la especialización,
la complejidad y la socialización. Ahora bien, y
¿cuáles son las tendencias a largo plazo de la tecnología?
Y de nuevo, mi pregunta es, ¿qué quiere la tecnología?
Y así, sorprendentemente, descubrí
que también hay una tendencia hacia la especialización.
Vemos que existe un martillo
y los martillos y se vuelven más y más específicos con el tiempo.
Existe, evidentemente, diversidad. Un gran número de cosas.
Éste es todo el contenido de una casa Japonesa.
De hecho tuve a mi hija -- le di un contador
y le encomendé el pasado verano que salga afuera
y contara cuántos tipos de tecnología hay en nuestro hogar.
Y contabilizó 6000 productos diferentes.
Hice algunas investigaciones y descubrí que el Rey de Inglaterra, Henry VIII,
tenía alrededor de 7000 artículos en su hogar.
Y él era el Rey de Inglaterra
y ahí se aglutinaba toda la riqueza de Inglaterra en el momento.
Entonces, estamos viendo un gran número de diversidad en el tipo de cosas.
Ésta es una escena de la "Guerra de las galaxias" cuando el 3PO sale
y descubre a las máquinas fabricando máquinas. ¡Qué degenerados!
Bueno, esto es, en realidad a lo que nos abocamos: hacia las máquinas mundo.
Y la tecnología sólo está siendo desplazada por otras tecnologías.
La mayoría de las máquinas solo estará en contacto con otras tecnologías
y con lo que no es tecnología, incluso con la vida.
Y en tercer lugar, la idea de que las máquinas se están volviendo complejas y biológicas
es un cliché. Y me alegra decir que
yo he sido en parte responsable del cliché de
que las máquinas se estén volviendo biológicas, pero eso es bastante evidente.
Por lo tanto, las principales tendencias en la evolución de la tecnología
son en realidad las mismas que en la evolución biológica. Se trata de lo mismo que lleva
hacia la omnipresencia, la diversidad, la socialización y
la complejidad. Quizá no es una gran sorpresa
porque si trazáramos el mapa, por ejemplo, de la evolución de la armadura,
podríamos en realidad ver la evolución en un cladograma de relaciones evolutivas.
De hecho, propongo que la tecnología se convierta en el séptimo reino de la vida.
Su sistematización y su funcionamiento son tan similares
que podemos pensar que es el séptimo reino.
Y por lo que sería aproximadamente el tipo de allá arriba,
saliendo desde el reino animal. Y si lo hiciéramos así,
descubriríamos que realmente se puede abordar la tecnología de esta manera.
Éste es Niles Eldredge, co-desarrollador con Stephen Jay Gould
de la teoría del equilibrio puntuado.
Asimismo, también se dedica a coleccionar cornetas.
Él cuenta con una de las más colecciones más grandes, alrededor de 500.
Y él ha decidido tratarlas como si fueran tribolites o caracoles
con el fin de hacer un análisis morfológico
y trazar la historia genealógica a través del tiempo.
Éste es el gráfico por ahora no publicado.
Pero el aspecto más interesante de esto
es que si nos fijamos en las líneas rojas en la parte inferior,
los que básicamente indican una filiación con un tipo de corneta
que ya no se fabrica. Esto no ocurre en biología.
Cuando algo se ha extinguido, no puede ser tu ancestro.
Pero sí ocurre en tecnología. Y resulta que
es tan sintomático que se puede observar el árbol
y usarlo para determinar
que se trata de un sistema tecnológico frente a un sistema biológico.
De hecho, este pensamiento de resucitar todo el conjunto de ideas
me llevó a pensar acerca de lo que ocurre con la vieja tecnología.
Y resulta que, de hecho, las tecnologías no mueren.
Así es que se lo propuse a un historiador de la ciencia, y dijo,
"Bueno, ¿qué pasa con los coches de vapor?
Ya no existen". Pero, en realidad, siguen existiendo.
De hecho, se puedes comprar nuevas piezas para un automóvil Stanley de vapor.
Éste es el sitio web dedicada a la venta de partes nuevas
para el automóvil Stanley. Y lo que me encanta
es poder añadir a la cesta de la compra a golpe de botón
(Risas)
así comprar válvulas de vapor. Es decir que es muy fácil acceder, realmente estaba ahí.
Por eso comencé a pensar, quizás se trata de sólo un ejemplo casual.
Debería quizá abordar el asunto de una forma más conservadora.
Así que agarré el catálogo de Montgomery Ward del 1895
y lo hojeé al azar. Me decidí por una página, no aleatoria,
Elegí una página en realidad más compleja que otras
porque muchas de las páginas están llenas de cosas
que todavía se fabrican. Pero me decidí por esta página
cuántas de estas cosas se fabrican todavía,
sin ser antigüedades. Quiero saber cuántas de estas cosas están todavía en producción.
Y la respuesta fue: todas.
Todas se siguen fabricando. Así es que Uds. tienes desgranadoras de maiz.
No sé quién necesita una desgranadora de maíz.
Ya bien desgranadoras de maíz, arados, molinos de viento,
todas estas cosas que han dejado de ser antigüedades. Todo se
puede ordenar. Usted puede ir a la web y se pueden comprar ahora,
nuevos de fábrica. Así que en cierto sentido, las tecnologías no mueren.
De hecho, se puede comprar, por 50 dólares, un cuchillo de la edad de piedra
piedra realizado exactamente de la misma manera que hace 10 000 años.
Corto, mango de hueso y cuesta sólo 50 dólares. Y
lo importante es que esta información realmente no muere.
No es sólo se haya resucitado. Se perpetúa en el tiempo.
Y en Papua Nueva Guinea hacían hachas de piedra
hasta hace dos décadas en un curso de contenidos prácticos.
Incluso cuando tratamos de renunciar a la tecnología, es realmente muy difícil.
Todos sabemos que los Amish renuncian a los automóviles.
Sabemos que los Japoneses renuncian a las armas.
Hemos oído hablar de esto y aquello. Pero en realidad mirando en retrospectiva
he constatado que existen ejemplos en la historia
donde se han establecido prohibiciones de la tecnología
y, he tratado de averiguar cuándo ocurrieron y cuando se volvieron a utilizar,
pues siempre reaparecieron. Y resulta que el espacio de tiempo
cuyo estado es ilegal o prohibido,
está reduciéndose. Y esto es así, porque, básicamente, se puede retardar la tecnología,
pero no se puede aniquilar. Y esto cobra sentido,
pues la cultura es la acumulación de ideas.
De eso se trata. Es para que las ideas no se extingan.
Y si partimos de ahí, tomamos esta idea de lo que aporta la cultura
y ampliada a lo largo del tiempo, de nuevo, nos topamos con la evolución de la vida,
nos precipitamos en cada uno de los casos, en cada una de las principales innovaciones en la vida,
que realmente están acelerando y cambiando
la manera en que ocurre la evolución.
Están cambiando la forma en que se forjan las ideas.
Así que todos estos pasos en la evolución van en aumento, son básicamente
la evolución de la evolucionabilidad.
Así lo que ocurre en la vida con el paso del tiempo es
que la manera cómo generamos las nuevas ideas, los nuevos artificios
van en aumento. Y el verdadero secreto estriba
en la forma en que se investiga la forma de investigar.
Y entonces comprobamos la singularidad tecnológica
profetizada por Kurzweil y otros
de que la tecnología está acelerando la evolución.
Está acelerando la forma en que buscamos ideas.
Así es que pirateamos vida,
la vida es saltarse las reglas es el juego de la supervivencia,
por tanto, la evolución es una manera de ampliar el juego al cambiar las reglas.
Y lo que realmente es la tecnología es una mejora en la manera de evolucionar.
Eso es lo que se denomina un juego infinito.
Ésa es la definición de juego infinito. En un juego finito se juega para ganar
ganar y en un juego infinito se juega para seguir jugando.
Y creo que la tecnología es en realidad una fuerza cósmica.
Los orígenes de la tecnología no comienzan en el año 1829,
sino comienza en realidad con el Big Bang,
en ese momento donde una enormidad de miles de millones de estrellas en el universo
se comprime. Todo el universo se comprime en minúsculos puntos cuánticos,
y estaban tan apretados que no había lugar para diferencias en absoluto.
Esa es la definición. No había temperatura.
No había ninguna diferencia en absoluto. Y en el Big Bang
lo que se expandió fue el potencial por la diferencia.
Por lo tanto, a medida que se expande y amplia las cosas dando paso a
una posibilidad potencial para la diferencia, la diversidad, las opciones,
las oportunidades, las posibilidades y las libertades.
A final, todos estos conceptos son básicamente lo mismo.
Y esto nos aporta la tecnología.
Eso es lo que nos aporta la tecnología: opciones, posibilidades, libertades.
De eso se trata. Es la expansión del espacio para crear diferencias.
Y cuando agarramos un martillo, es lo que estamos agarrando, un martillo.
Y por eso seguimos agarrándonos a la tecnología,
porque nos conviene. Son cosas buenas.
Diferencias, libertad, opciones, posibilidades.
Y cada vez que creamos una nueva oportunidad,
estamos permitiendo una plataforma para generar otras nuevas.
Y creo que es realmente importante. Porque imagínense a
Mozart antes de la invención tecnológica del piano,
vaya una pérdida para la sociedad.
Imagínense que Van Gogh hubira nacido
antes de la invención de los óleos asequibles.
Imagínense a Hitchcock antes de la tecnología cinematográfica.
En alguna parte, hoy, hay millones de niños que nacen
sin que se haya inventado todavía la tecnología para expresarse libremente .
Tenemos la obligación moral de desarrollar tecnología
para que cada persona del planeta disfrute del potencial
para plasmar su verdadero carácter diferenciador.
Queremos tropecientos millones de especies particulares.
A eso es a lo que realmente aspira la tecnología.
Voy a pasar por alto algunas objeciones
porque no tengo respuestas a la deforestación.
No tengo una respuesta al hecho de que existan, lo que parecen ser,
malas tecnologías. No tengo una respuesta a
cómo ello repercute en nuestra dignidad, a no ser para sugerir
que tal vez el séptimo reino, por estar tan próximo a la vida,
tal vez pueda contribuir a ayudarnos a controlar la vida.
Quizá de alguna manera
estamos tratando de encontrar a la tecnología un buen hogar para desarrollarse.
La fumigación en los campos de algodón DDT es algo terrible,
sin embargo, es muy útil para
eliminar millones de casos de muerte por malaria en un pequeño pueblo.
Nuestra humanidad en realidad está definida por la tecnología.
Todas las cosas que creemos que realmente nos gustan de la humanidad
se promueven a través y por la tecnología. Éste es el juego infinito.
Eso es de lo que estamos hablando.
La tecnología es una manera de que la evolución evolucione.
Es una manera de explorar las posibilidades y oportunidades y crear más.
Y es en realidad una forma de jugar el juego, de jugar todos los juegos.
A eso aspira la tecnología.
Por eso, cuando pienso a lo que aspira la tecnología,
creo que está relacionado con el hecho de que cada persona aquí, y estoy convencido de ello,
cada persona tiene una misión. Y la misión es
ir por la vida descubriendo cuál es su cometido.
Y su naturaleza recursiva es el juego infinito.
Y que si juegas bien, tendrás otras personas involucradas
de manera que el juego se expande y continúa incluso cuando ya no estés.
Éste es el juego infinito. Y la tecnología es
el canal donde se desarrolla ese juego infinito.
Y así creo que debemos abrazar la tecnología,
ya que es una parte esencial de nuestro camino
en saber lo que somos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)